[Musique]
Isabelle Tard, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
On vous reçoit parce que vous intéressez
tout un tas de sujets, mais aussi parce
que vous êtes ex-député
Europe écologie les vert dans dans le
nord Pascalis. C'est ça.
Mais c'est la classe en géographie. Non.
Calvados.
Plage de l'hébarquement. Tu diras des
plages aussi.
C'est un peu plus. Non, c'était fait
exprès. Comment allez-vous ?
Très bien.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Euh, alors je suis
archéozologue,
ex-directrice de musée,
ex-député, écologiste et pas que élevé.
Euh
je suis la très heureuse mère de quatre
jeunes hommes qui m'ont formé aussi de
leur côté. beaucoup d'échanges familiaux
qui m'ont fait évoluer surtout ces
derniers temps et euh j'ai la sensation
là maintenant ces jours-ci d'entamer
presque une 6e vie. Voilà avec une une
vraie réflexion, beaucoup de remise en
question et voilà.
Bon un député ça palp combien ?
Alors, on va dire député classique parce
que pas président de commission ou
vice-président de l'assemblée et cetera,
c'est 5400 € net par mois.
Vous avez fait 5 ans ?
5 ans.
Vous avez mis des sous de côté un peu ?
Non,
j'ai beaucoup donné aux parties à qui
j'appartenais. Vous
entendez par beaucoup de données ?
1200 à 1300 en moyenne 1200 € par mois.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'était la règle.
Voilà, c'est très simple hein. Après,
chaque chaque partie a ses propres
règles, a ses propres sommes.
Euh donc voilà, moi je reversais, j'ai
mis un petit peu de côté, j'ai aussi un
petit peu financé les études de mes
garçons. Euh
et puis et puis voilà.
Bon, maintenant, vous vous touchez
combien ? Vous faites quoi ?
Je suis au chômage euh depuis un peu
plus d'un an. Euh les indimités de
d'anciens députés sont dégressives et
aujourd'hui, je perçois 2400 € par mois
et je vais je suis donc en reconversion.
Pourquoi avoir choisi Europe écologie
les verts ? Alors ça ça fait ça c'était
il y a longtemps euh
si je enfin quand j'ai voulu euh
effectivement euh m'intéresser à la
politique et être actrice on va dire euh
au niveau politique en tant que
militante, c'est quasiment le seul
parti.
Actrice c'est quoi ? C'est jouer un rôle
?
Participer, c'est militer. J'aurais dû
dire militante je pense mais voilà,
c'était
aider, faire partie d'un collectif qui
se bouge. Bah c'était le seul parti.
J'ai adhéré au vert d'abord, après ils
ont changé le nom vert. Euh je j'ai
adhéré assez tard parce que j'étais pas
en France pendant une grande partie de
ma vie. Vous
étiez où ?
En Laponie. En Laponie Suédoise. Et
ah et avant vous étiez à Godborg, c'est
ça ?
Voilà. Good Godborg. Après, je suis
parti au nord du cercle polaire et
j'avais créé une petite entreprise
là-bas. J'ai vécu 7 ans.
Le tourisme.
Dans le tourisme, ouais. conseillère
consultante en tourisme. J'ai essayé de
de trouver Ah, je crois que ça aurait
plu à Macron ce que j'ai fait. Je crois
vraiment que ça lui aurait plu. C'était
euh petite entreprise, une petite PME où
je faisais du guidage, du je traduisais,
je formais les les entreprises locales
et le personnel de l'hôtellerie et
cetera aux Français. Voilà, parce qu'ils
accueillaient beaucoup d'allemands,
beaucoup de Japonais avec un pouvoir
d'achat extrêmement élevé et puis les
touristes francophones bof. Donc voilà,
je me suis dit, je vais faire faire ma
part. J'ai me trouvé un petit créneau.
Donc j'organisais des safari motoneiges
avec les chiens de traîneau.
C'est pas très écologiste la motonige.
Pas du tout. Non, c'était pas du tout
écolo. J'aime bien expliquer. J'ai même
travaillé chez McDo en Suède.
Pourquoi les Français ont perdu
confiance dans leur politique ?
Parce qu'il y a pas de cohérence. parce
qu'il y a c'est pas suffisamment strict,
c'est pas suffisamment
euh puissant en terme de règles de
démocratie et je pense que c'est tout à
fait logique ce qui arrive aujourd'hui.
Vous avez perdu confiance dans la
politique vous ?
Oui.
Oui. Oui.
Pourquoi ?
Je sais pas si au départ quand quand je
milite et que je me dis bon bah tiens,
pourquoi pas euh être candidate pour les
pour les législatives ?
Je pense que j'avais une certaine
candeur dans la politique, c'est-à-dire
j'avais une certaine image qui est
probablement celle du français moyen
dans la politique, dans l'image qu'on a
de la politique.
C'est quoi cette image ? de dire
de dire que finalement les responsables
politiques ou les élus à l'Assemblée au
Sna forcément super intelligents. Euh
que
non euh que euh on prend les décisions à
l'assemblée, c'est pas le cas. Euh
quelle image j'avais ? Ouais, je me
sentais finalement une fois alors que
j'étais élu, j'avais quand même un petit
bagage scientifique
un petit peu politique perso,
j'étais impressionnée. Je me disais
"Waouh, je vais je vais arriver dans un
hémicycle bourré de gens super doués et
super intelligents et euh j'étais
impressionné. Ça a pas duré très
longtemps mais cette candur, je l'ai
perdu hein, je rassure tout le monde.
Bon, on commence à faire saigner les
murs maintenant ou on attend encore un
peu ?
Quand vous voulez.
OK. L'écologie, la démission de Nicolas
Hul là, ça vous a fait quoi ?
Donc j'ai fait j'ai écrit un petit
article où il y avait j'avais écrit
"C'est pas une surprise et et c'est pas
un acte courageux."
Pour moi, c'était pas un acte de
courage. C'était le courage aurait été
de jamais y rentrer
dans ce gouvernement. Il était au
courant dès le départ de l'orientation
politique d'Emmanuel Macron et de son
gouvernement. il y va en toute
conscience. Euh il sait qu'il est tout
seul,
euh qu'il a en face de lui, enfin qu'il
a à ses côtés, on va dire, un premier
ministre issu du lobbying du nucléaire.
Euh
il assume, après qu'on dise, il qu'il
disent après j'ai rien pu faire et
cetera. Bah, j'aurais on aurait pu lui
dire tous qu'il avait qu'il aurait rien
pu faire. Ne ne me dites pas qu'il a
découvert les lobby en 2017 quoi. C'est
c'est pas possible. Donc non, s'il était
vraiment écolo, responsable, euh
cohérent avec ses positions précédentes,
il avait pas y rentrer.
C'est tout.
C'est quoi le problème avec
la ligne de Macron avec l'écologie ?
Bah disons que la ligne de Macron, c'est
l'ultralibéralisme,
c'est la continuité du capitalisme,
c'est
un tatoucher à la française.
Essayz de me essayer de me résumer ça.
Ça a rien à voir avec c'est le contraire
de ce qu'on attend d'un d'un responsable
politique conscient des de l'écologie
aujourd'hui.
C'est quoi le problème avec le
capitalisme et l'écologie ?
C'est incompatible.
C'est totalement incompatible.
Il faut dire pourquoi
je vais pouvoir développer. C'est ça qui
est intéressant. C'est je considère que
le capitalisme nous a conduit dans le
mur dans lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui
par rapport à l'utilisation des
ressources, les choix qui ont été les
nôtres. Alors je dis les nôtres, je mets
pas toute la planète dans le même dans
le même panier. les nôtres, tous ceux
qui en pays occidentaux
dit très développé. La ligne qui a été
choisie depuis des décennies et pas
seulement depuis la deuxème guerre
mondiale, c'est celle d'utilisation
maximum des ressources. On se fout
royalement de savoir quelles sont les
limites. On fait confiance à la science
qui trouvera des solutions.
Euh, on se fout également de savoir si
les humains vont bien de manière
globale, du moment que quelques-uns
réussissent.
Et on aboutit à la situation
d'aujourd'hui avec
les burnouts, les chômeurs, les les gens
qui en ont le bol, qui qui trouvent pas
leur place dans la société, qui donnent
qui n'ont pas de sens dans à leur vie et
qui vont accepter des boulots de merde
parce que avec le super revenu universel
d'activité, ils vont devoir l'accepter
sinon ils crèvent. Euh pour moi, c'est
totalement impossible. c'est d'imaginer
que ça peut ça peut être ne serait-ce
qu'un peu compatible avec euh avec
l'écologie.
On parle pas de biodiversité, de choses
comme ça.
Quand je dis euh qu'on a épuisé nos
ressources, c'est également on a on a on
a pioché dans la biodiversité. On on est
la 6e extinction des espèces
euh où j'entends beaucoup effectivement
des gens qui me disent "Mais il y en a
déjà eu Alors oui, c'est un petit peu
mon travail hein en tant
qu'archéosologue de regarder au niveau
de la biodiversité ce qui s'est passé,
comment l'homme a fait opérer la
surchasse, la surpêche et cetera. OK.
Simplement là aujourd'hui, on en est à
un degré complètement différent. Euh
c'est exponentiel, on a jamais eu ça.
Donc euh
les questions les bonnes questions à se
poser, c'est quelle est notre part de
responsabilité ? Les gens ils sont
tabassent en fait quand quand Nicolas
Hulou a a démissionné euh
nous on a regardé ça comme des passagers
clandestins. On a regarder son compte
Twitter, on a vu 307000 abonnés, on
s'est dit "Oh, ça va peut-être faire des
petites vagues." Et puis selon la
police, paraît-il qu'il y avait 50000
personnes dans les rues pour la marche,
pour le climat, ça représente combien de
pourcentage de de son compte Twitter ?
Pas beaucoup. Hm hm.
Les gens il ils sont préoccupés par
d'autres par d'autres choses. Non,
je suis pas
Ils ont peut-être confiance dans la
science.
Une partie, je suis persuadée qu'une
partie a confiance. Une grande partie
parce que ça a été un lettre motive. Ils
ont raison.
Ah non non non.
Pourquoi non ? Non, parce que alors là,
je rejoins euh totalement Alain Damasioo
euh quand il explique enfin qui valorise
son néologisme, le très humanisme plus
important que le transhumanisme. C'est
exactement ça. Non, j'y crois pas du
tout parce que euh les Happy Few qui
vont partir euh sur Mars grâce à Elon
Musk,
OK, en quoi ça en quoi ça m'intéresse ?
En quoi ça nous concerne nous ?
Absolument pas. Donc si c'est pour tous
crever sur terre pendant qu'il y en a
quelques-uns qui vont aller s'amuser à
faire les gugus sur une autre planète
ou conquérir le système solaire.
Pourquoi pas ? Ayons la folie des
grandeurs. Conquérir le système solaire.
Génial. Euh bah ça m'intéresse pas plus
hein. Ça m'intéresse pas plus.
Ça franchir de la plebe non.
Alors là on rentre dans la série
trépalium euh où on va faire un mur
entre la plebe et puis les quelques-uns
qui vont vivre correctement. Lysséum.
Non,
ça je connais pas
aussi.
J'ai pas vu. C'est c'est dans le même
genre. Je suis très euh très inspiré par
enfin je trouve les séries dystopiques
très inspirantes en tout cas et qui qui
nous oblige à réfléchir sur la direction
que nous avons prise collectivement,
ce qu'on peut comment on peut faire
autrement. Euh
je disais tout à l'heure, j'étais
certainement candide au départ. Je pense
que dans les gens qui s'imaginaient que
Nicolas Hul allait faire des un super
résultat à l'écologie, il y a beaucoup
de candides et beaucoup de naïfs,
beaucoup de bisous nours euh qui n'ont
jamais regardé qui euh euh finançait la
fondation Nicolas Hul par exemple. Je
quand on quand on a des grandes
multinationales qui financent sa
fondation,
des philanthropes.
Oui, oui, bien sûr. C'est qui déjà ?
C'est c'est c'est Rockfeller qui
finançait aussi euh
des fondations aussi. Non mais je veux
dire faut pas tout gober.
Yan Artus Bertrand fait son documentaire
financé par la fondation B en cours. Ça
vous pose pas de problème ?
Beaucoup de problèmes. J'ai jamais fait
de pub avec Artus Bertrand. Ça me gêne
profondément. Et j'essaie de d'expliquer
pourquoi aussi. J'essaie d'expliquer
pourquoi je considère Nicola Hulo comme
un Nico Tartuf. Je l'ai je l'ai dit, je
l'ai écrit, je l'ai je l'ai expliqué. Je
suis pas la seule. Vous proposiez quoi
euh quand vous étiez à Europe écologie
les verts ?
Alors, j'ai Ouais. Je suis restée
jusqu'en décembre 2013
et on avait un programme pour la
présidentielle qui était qui était
sympa. Vivre mieux. Je pense que si on
l'avait
tenu, c'était pas mal du tout à l'époque
hein, faut se situer dans le contexte.
Euh
des choses concrètes vivre.
Ouais. Non non si c'est on parlait déjà
du revenu de base quand même. Euh il y
avait une répartition, il y avait plus
de répartition des richesses forcément.
Enfin je l'ai pas je l'ai pas toujours
en tête mais d'un point de vue social et
économique c'était quand même
intéressant et je je regrette pas du
tout. J'assume le fait qu'il y ait eu
cet accord avec le PS euh parce qu'on
savait très bien que enfin
ils vous l'ont mis profond quand même le
PS pour ils vous ont dit on va sortir du
nucléaire Pasculin pour avoir vos voix
et pour faire passer Hollande non tout à
fait on savait très bien que Hollande
était était tous au fécol pourquoi
bah il a jamais eu ben OPS il a jamais
eu de d'actes forts montrant qu'il était
préoccupé par l'écologie bon donc on se
faisait pas d'illusion à ce moment-là
Euh mais on se disait tiens, on a
peut-être une occasion toute relative
euh de verdir sa politique ou de de
comme on sera dans la majorité,
peut-être on aura l'occasion de faire
quelque chose de vraiment écolo.
C'était pas simplement de
l'opportunisme.
Je pense que pour certains, il y avait
beaucoup d'opportunismes
qui
parmi mes collègues députés à ce
moment-là.
Votre parole n'engage que vous.
Tout à fait.
Bon, moi je m'étais présenté euh aux
législatives pour me préparer pour les
municipales.
Euh je m'étais dit "Je suis pas très
connu" bon et je savais que j'avais
envie de faire des choses intéressantes
enfin tenter quelque chose pour au
niveau local.
Donc je me suis entraînée, je me suis
très bien entraînée et donc j'ai été élu
député. Je me suis dit bon on peut faire
aussi énormément de choses.
Certainement.
C'est ce que tout le monde croit encore
que les députés ont un pouvoir, que on a
notre mot à dire et que nos votes
finalement
reflète un certain travail. Ça, on va on
pourra peut-être revenir là-dessus. Je
crois que c'est pas du pas du tout ça.
Les lobby sont extrêmement efficaces et
les décisions viennent du gouvernement.
Point. Et c'est pire aujourd'hui vu la
majorité macroniste à l'Assemblée. C'est
bien pire.
De quoi prendre cette posture victimaire
?
victime, on est de dire qu'on peut rien
faire à l'assemblée.
Ah, il y a les lobby
pourquoi vous organisez pas en en
phalange romaine ?
Ah, j'aurais adoré.
Ah, le coup de créer un groupe rebelle,
je l'ai essayé. Et
rebelle structuré
bien sûr. Structuré.
On reproche toujours aux écologistes. Je
me fais l'avocat du diable, je suis très
dur. C'est vrai, c'est super.
Merci. le on repche toujours aux
écologistes d'être des babacou avec des
chiens à fumer des joints à se balader
avec des cheveux sale.
C'est marrant parce que là tu es en
train de me décrire plutôt le portrait
euh du zadiste. Euh enfin tel qu'il
tel qu'il est tel qu'il est décrit par
ceux qui les aiment pas, ce qui n'est
pas mon cas. Et tu aurais pu rajouter
dans la description d'ailleurs ce que
Jean-Vincent Placé disait avec le pull
en laine qui gratte pour les écolos.
Voilà, c'est pas euh je reviens sur le
côté victimaire dont tu me parlais tout
à l'heure, c'est je pense que c'est
important justement d'expliquer comment
ça se passe concrètement à l'assemblée
euh sans aucune langue de bois, sans
sans rien cacher aux gens pour qu'ils se
réveillent et qu' se disent est-ce qu'on
peut faire autrement ? Est-ce que ça
sert à quelque chose toujours d'aller
voter pour les députés ? Qu'est-ce que
j'attends de mes élus et cetera ? OK, je
me suis souvent posé la question. Je me
suis dit des fois est-ce que j'explique
aux gens vraiment comment ça se passe de
l'intérieur ou euh quitte à les dégoûter
et à ce qu'il ne croit pas tellement
c'est voilà peu intéressant.
Où est-ce que j'explique ? Je prends le
temps d'expliquer vraiment le
fonctionnement de l'assemblée. Bon, j'ai
opté pour expliquer vraiment le
fonctionnement de l'assemblée.
Alors, vous expliquez correctement ou
vous expliquez pas correctement ? Non,
je pense que je suis assez lucide sur
euh euh sur l'organisation des travaux
euh qui ça s'est accentué, je trouve
hein. J'ai suivi quand même un petit peu
ce qui se passe depuis euh depuis juin
2017. Je trouve que on est euh c'est
c'est il y a pas le temps de travailler.
Les textes arrivent euh tous les tous
les tr jours devant sur les bureaux des
députés. C'est bah clé, c'est des
weekends entiers. Bon, travailler de
nuit, ça a jamais été bon pour personne.
C'est pas c'est pas mieux pour nous.
C'était pas mieux pour nous. Les
conditions de travail sont sont
complètement nazes. Euh on n pas le
temps d'approfondir chaque dossier. Il
faudrait qu'on ait 40 à 600
parlementaires qui bossent chacun une
partie. Donc on est obligé de
sélectionner des sujets plus que
d'autres. Et effectivement, quand je
disais les lobby tout à l'heure, c'est
que je voyais bien les amendements
amenés par des lobby importants euh être
relu
par différentes personnes de groupes
différents à l'assemblée. Et pourquoi on
le savait ? Parce que les coquilles
étaient restées.
Il y a des gens qui gagnent moins de
1300 € qui travaillent jour et nuit
contre trois gamins.
C'est ça.
Il touchent pas 5900 €.
Non.
Non non, mais quand on a la je parle de
responsabilité, quand on a la
responsabilité de rédiger une loi qui va
impacter tout un pays,
euh on a intérêt à avoir les idées
claires, à avoir écouté tout le monde, à
s'être fait une opinion soi-même
éclairée
euh d'avoir pris le temps de le faire.
Moi je je peux pas supporter qu'on bacle
ou qu'on vote parce qu'on me dit de
voter ça ou je vois mes collègue voter
donc je fais pareil, je me réveille
c'est pas possible.
Il y a de la prise de stupéfiant, il y a
de l'alcoolisme au sein de l'assemblée.
L'alcoolisme oui.
Les stupéfiants.
Des stupéfiants, je sais pas mais je
sais que dans les Macrons, il y avait eu
des
des petits produits qui circulaient qui
avaient été commandés.
Quel type ? Qui par où ? Je crois que
c'était Alain Touré qui
tu de vos sources.
Ouais.
C'était pas des faux Macron ?
Je crois pas.
Je faut faire attention mise en examen x
mais
on est en direct là.
Ah ou on est en direct. Non mais
ça c'était ce qui était sorti. Après
c'est pas forcément enfin forcément
vrai. Pas forcément lui, j'en sais rien.
Simplement
l'alcool. Oui,
ça
c'est ça pose aussi un autre problème.
Ça leur permet de tenir. C'est parce que
ils ont un choc cognitif, une dissonance
cognitive entre ce qu'ils sont obligés
de voter, les problèmes qu'ils sont
obligés de gérer. C'est quoi ? C'est une
fuite en avant, c'est
c'est de l'alcool festif. Ils sont
peut-être pas tous
Non mais non, c'est pas tout le monde.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est que pour moi
c'était déjà trop. Enfin le la quantité
absorbée, c'était déjà trop. Je compare
souvent avec un un pays que je connais
bien aussi qui est la Suède avec le
comportement des des parlementaires.
Jamais un parlementaire suédois ne boit
de l'alcool quand il siège au Parlement.
Alors les seedois c'est particulier, ils
boivent mais à partir du vendredi soir
jusqu'au dimanche et après pendant 5
jours, il y a rien. Alors ça crée des
chocs des chocs thermiques mais mais
c'est pas du tout la même conception de
la de la vie et de l'alcoolisme
particulier.
Notre démocratie en est où là ?
Et bien c'est ce que je disais il y a
pas longtemps. J'ai jamais enfin ces ces
dernières années, je considère pas que
nous sommes en démocratie. Nous sommes
en République et c'est pas pareil.
Une démocratie, est-ce que on se réfère
au modèle de la démocratie athénienne ?
Bah, ça se passait pas comme ça. C'est
pas forcément avec des représentants
élus. Je je ne considère pas que nous
sommes en démocratie.
Vous avez peur de dire des choses ?
Non.
Non. Non.
Vous avez peur ? peur de les dire ? Euh
non, j'ai rien à perdre.
C'est une question d'internet, hein. La
question c'est de quoi de quoi a-t-elle
peur en ce moment même ?
Qu'est-ce qu'elle a peur de dire ? Euh
j'ai pas peur. Euh je me prépare, c'est
différent. Et en ce moment euh
j'ai pris en compte la notion
d'effondrement.
On va y venir.
Ouais.
Mais c'est pas une peur.
Une question d'Internet, un commentaire
sur le vote contre le glyphosate.
Est-ce que est-ce que question ?
Est-ce que la République en marche la
semaine prochaine va nous annoncer
quelque chose de très important ?
C'est-à-dire qu'ils acceptent encore une
fois que il y ait aucune décision de
prise.
Peut-être pas,
peut-être pas.
Euh sur le glyphosate, je considère que
là, il y a peut-être eu une erreur
stratégique de la part de des groupes
d'opposition français insoumise compris.
C'est-à-dire que euh oui, on sait que le
groupe majoritaire met des votes
importants en plein milieu de la nuit et
cetera, mais je pense aussi qu'il y a
des votes symboliques où il faut que
tout le monde soit là. Voilà.
Question d'Internet. Est-ce qu'elle
croit encore à Europe, l'écologie les
verts entre rugie, placé, conbédite
sont-ils encore crédibles ? Alors euh je
je je fais une petite explication de
texte. Aucun de tous les noms qui
viennent d'être cités n'appartiennent à
Europécologie les verts. Ils sont plus
dans ce parti. Euh je sais qu'il y a
encore des militants très sympas qui y
croient, qui bossent dans dans ELV, mais
personnellement ça fait belle du raette
que je crois plus à aucun parti.
Donc pas plus dans celui-là qu'un autre.
Vous C'est plutôt l'anarchie ? Non,
c'est même totalement l'anarchie. Et
j'aimerais juste qu'on puisse expliquer
un petit peu plus que l'anarchie c'est
pas le chaos, c'est pas le bordel,
c'est l'autogestion. Alors, souvent on
tourne autour du pot et c'est ça me gêne
un peu. Mais après tout, si on préfère
utiliser le terme autogestion, euh
allons-y. Et je pense que c'est
important d'envisager l'anarchie comme
euh modèle économique et modèle social
et plus particulièrement l'écoarchie.
Écologie et anarchie, ça va ensemble à
mes yeux. tout comme on peut rajouter un
troisème une troisème partie qui est le
féminisme. Et pour moi, les trois sont
indissociables et nous permettent de de
d'inventer finalement un modèle de
société pour plus tard.
C'est quoi plus tard ?
Plus tard, ça sera après l'effondrement.
C'est l'effondrement vous basez sur quoi
?
Alors, c'est très intéressant parce que
je pense avoir fait un un déni total
pendant très longtemps sur tout ce qui
était euh rapport mesdoses euh études
scientifiques et je le dis très
franchement, je pense que on aurait dû
en tant que nous députés écologistes
être les premiers au courant, être les
premiers conscients.
Euh c'est étrange. J'ai retrouvé en il y
a quelques mois en déménageant le
rapport que Pablo Servigne avait fait
pour Yve Coch au Parlement européen.
Ouais bah je l'avais donc reçu hein.
C'est nourrir le nourrir l'Europe. Yfet
qui prévoyait le la fin des compagnies
aériennes il y a il y a 5 ou 6 ans. 7
ans peut-être 8 ans.
Ouais. Non, mais il y a pas mal de gens
qui prévoyaient beaucoup de choses, mais
euh euh d'un point de vue scientifique,
certains faits, les dossier euh ont
quand même été publiés. Bon, on peut
choisir après de les
rassembler, de d'en faire un un livre un
peu plus conséquent, on fait un rapport.
Bref, ce rapport, je l'avais, on me l'a
envoyé, je l'ai mis de côté, je l'ai
jamais ouvert.
Euh je sais pas pourquoi, j'ai ma petite
explication. Je me dis que pendant les
dernières années, il y avait des sujets
brûlants à l'assemblée avec la tête dans
le guidon, la loi les lois
renseignement,
loi terrorisme, tout ce qui était
liberticide et cetera et cetera, tout
tous les sujets numériques. Euh pour
moi, je me suis concentrée sur ces
sujets-là et j'ai pas regardé ailleurs.
J'aurais dû. Bon, c'est pas grave, il
est jamais trop tard. Mais euh voilà,
c'est aujourd'hui, j'en suis à un moment
de quoi le rapport MDOS ? Il
fait des scénarios, différents scénarios
en prenant tous les critères de
population, enfin démographie,
économique,
biodiversité et cetera et il testent
effectivement différents scénarios.
Donc ça date de 72, c'est ça je crois.
Por meso 72.
Euh
je sais qu'on en a parlé, j'ai des
souvenirs où on mentionne ce rapport et
chez moi ça fait pas tilte quoi du tout.
J'ai un père écolo antinucléaire qui
a milité toute sa vie et
je me dis bah oui, j'étais dans ce
milieulà, j'étais consciente de pas mal
de choses euh mais j'étais loin d'avoir
tout lu et j'étais loin de la prise de
conscience d'aujourd'hui.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe si on rentre dans
un système de décroissance avec notre
système financier mondialisé ?
Je pars pas, j'analyse pas les choses de
cette façon-là. C'est une question.
Ouais. Euh je pense que le système
financier ou la crise financière qui qui
arrivera puisqu'on a refait les mêmes
conneries qu'avant 2008 euh
fait que on pourra pas continuer à vivre
de la même façon
et que on est obligé et que nous serons
obligés
de modifier notre façon de vivre. Donc
c'est pas comme si on allait tous
devenir des croissants maintenant.
Quelle était ma question ?
la décroissance aujourd'hui, est-ce que
c'est possible dans le monde financier
dans lequel on est ? C'est ça ta
question.
Sans passer par un chale plus total.
Je pas forcément parler de chaos. Euh
pour moi, la décroissance aujourd'hui,
ça fait partie d'un mode de vie. C'est
un choix de vie de façon à avoir le
moins le moins d'impact possible sur
cette planète.
On en est tous à des chemins différents
où certains s'en foutent, d'autres ont
décidé de de partir habiter dans la
forêt et cetera. OK.
On est régi par la finance.
C'est la finance qui domine tout. C'est
la finance qui domine la politique.
C'est la finance qui permet de financer
les entreprises. C'est la finance qui
permet de fluidifier les échanges.
Parce qu'on a vécu dans ce système là
depuis depuis qu'on étudie, on va dire,
l'économie.
On va, on est depuis de siècles dans un
système où c'est comme ça que ça se
passe et on on ne regarde absolument pas
quel pourrait être un autre
fonctionnement de l'économie. Si on
regarde l'économie en terme de
d'autogestion
avec des avec des coopératives, avec des
gens qui décide eux-mêmes, avec des
actionnaires qui reçoivent moins de
dividende avec de l'argent qui n'est pas
réinvesti, qui n'est pas donné aux
actionnaires mais qui peut être
réinvesti dans une entreprise
pour consommer.
Pardon,
pour consommer,
non pas pour consommer.
Et euh c'est pour ça aussi que j'ai j'ai
toujours eu beaucoup de mal avec la
notion de productivisme, avec le fait de
défendre euh des entreprises qui vont
consommer toujours plus. Je sais pas si
je suis très claire,
je pense que de vouloir produire plus de
voitures, non, ça m'intéresse pas. Donc
je suis pas prête à défendre
les emplois dans ce secteurlà.
parce que je je considère que ça ça
participe au fait d'aller dans le mur.
Euh je préférais défendre une
reconversion
avec des gens qui bossent dans dans
d'autres domaines.
cette idée de on va tous aller beaucoup
mieux, si on produit plus de bien et
puis on va obliger les gens à on va les
inciter à acheter en faisant vachement
de publicité. On est dans le dans le
modèle typique de surtout de l'après-dè
guerre mondiale. C'est une inflation de
de biens de consommation, une création
du désir d'acheter qui n'a plus de
limite, qui n'a pas de limite.
Ça s'arrête quand ? Ça s'arrête quand ?
Quelle é
on est déjà à quatre planètes. Donc
quelle était ma question ?
Est-ce que la décroissance
peut fonctionner dans le dans le modèle
financier actuel ?
Qu'est-ce pass ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe
quand on a un modèle décroissant dans le
modèle financier actuel
d'flation ?
Je vous laisse continuer.
C'est encore une fois
c'est peut-être notre seule arme d'agir
sur la consommation.
Nous, si on veut essayer d'influencer
les choix politiques, les choix qui sont
faits de choix de société,
on a une arme qui est la façon
d'utiliser notre argent. Certains ont
même proposé de sortir l'argent des
banques. Bon,
c'est pas concevable.
C'est pas c'est pas concevable par la
population aujourd'hui. C'est pas c'est
pas juste pas possible.
Réfléchissons comment on peut
fonctionner différemment.
Comment on peut voilà c'est c'est
vous prévoyez vous prévoyez une zone
tampon entre le changement de
Je prévois rien. Je prévois rien. Je
suis pas madame Irma. Je regarde pas
dans une boule de cristal. Je me dis
juste que il faut tout regarder.
Il faut envisager des solutions, des
façons de vivre différentes.
C'est tout. et je prétends pas donner
des conseils.
Non, j'ai juste pris conscience de
certaines choses de notre façon de vivre
qui de ma façon de vivre
de ces dernières années et qui ne peut
plus durer.
Est-ce que Est-ce que les décroissances
sont dangereux pour le système financier
?
Non. Non, mais honnêtement non.
Pourquoi ? parce que euh ils ont c'est
c'est des gens qui ont effectivement
décidé de pas être de rentrer dans le
système, de pas être dans le système
dans lequel nous vivons aujourd'hui et
euh et c'est des gens en rébellion.
Est-ce que les adistes sont dangereux
pour le système dans lequel nous vivons
aujourd'hui ?
Oui,
il représente l'image d'une société qui
est aux antipodes du capitalisme.
Ce qui se passe sur l'Azad, c'est ça en
fait.
Et pourquoi il y a 2500 CRS ? Pourquoi
il y a il y a autant de force de l'ordre
pour 300 pékin ? C'est bien parce qu'il
représente une menace. Il pourrait
donner des idées aux autres.
Ils étaient beaucoup plus de que ça les
forces de leur dernière fois. Non,
c'était pas 2000.
C'est ce que j'ai dit. 2500.
Merci.
Ouais. Ouais. 2500 on y était.
Voilà. Si s'il y a si ça déchaîne autant
les passions s'il y a autant de monde
contre eux au niveau enfin par rapport
aux violences policières. Pourquoi
certaines manifes ont autant de de
fourgons de CRS autour et parce que ça
représente le danger pour pour l'État.
C'est pas la marche pour le climat qui
représente un danger pour le
gouvernement.
Mais l'État c'est pas nous.
Ah non non,
ça c'est ce qu'on apprend. Enfin, c'est
ce qu'on ce qu'on nous fait croire pour
qu'on puisse ensuite dire qu'on vit en
démocratie.
Les pas l'État c'est pas nous. l'État,
c'est des élus qui arrivent à être élus
par une petite part de la population
aujourd'hui euh par le biais beaucoup de
clientélisme,
de chanta de de chantage à l'emploi et
cetera. Oui, c'est ça. Les élus
aujourd'hui, c'est une classe, une
caste.
On fait comment pour
question d'internet ? Qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire en tant que citoyen pour
mettre la pression à un député ? Et je
dirais en en extrapolant la question,
comment on fait pour se faire entendre
et se faire écouter de cette fameuse
caste que vous décrivez ? Il y a
quelques temps, je je disais
vous écrivez et puis s'il y a 500
courriers, 500 mails identiques qui
demandent la même chose,
le député va dire "Ah attention, sujet
dangereux, alerte, 500 personnes de ma
circonscription
ont un avis visiblement assez assez fort
sur un sujet. Euh j'ai peut-être intérêt
à les écouter.
Euh aujourd'hui, je sais pas, je je suis
pas convaincu que que ça soit le la
force citoyenne qui fasse entendre qui
puisse faire changer d'avis un député.
Euh
il faut quand même essayer mais comme
j'ai beaucoup de mal à croire au
changement qui arriverait par les
par des députés ou par des sénateurs ou
même par un gouvernement, j'ai j'ai du
mal à vous, si je suis cohérente à vous
dire allez convaincre votre député.
Ça sert à quelque chose de manifester ?
Je crois pas.
Je vais essayer d'expliquer.
Je crois en la grève générale.
Oui. C'està-dire un blocage.
C'est dangereux ça, non ?
Euh bah oui, mais c'est le but si vous
voulez changer quelque chose. Les
libertés, elles se donneent pas, elles
se prennent.
Soit vous voulez changer le changer le
modèle, changer le système dans lequel
on vit, on on fait des actions un peu
plus punchy, soit on fait une petite
marche en ville. C'est quoi des actions
punchy ? C'est la violence.
Ah, super question. Euh,
je suis quelqu'un de non violent.
Ça a pas l'air comme ça, hein.
Ah si, si si, j'ai encore rien cassé là.
Euh,
donc je suis quelqu'un de non violent
mais d'un autre côté, c'est pas moi qui
vais tendre l'autre jour.
C'est je pense que les mouvements non
violents ont leur importance mais ils
n'auraient pas eu l'ampleur qu'ils ont
eu s'il y avait pas eu des copuscules ou
des activistes qui s'étaient bougé pour
faire parler d'eux sur d'autres sujets.
C'est que je pense pas que Martin Luther
King aurait eu le même impact s'il avait
pas eu Malcomic et je pense pas non plus
que Gandy aurait eu la même les mêmes
résultats s'il y avait pas eu des
activistes en Inde dont on parle jamais
quasiment. Voilà.
Si je vous dis la violence et la force
des faibles et comment s'arrête les
connaissances ? Pense c'est cetteitation
que vous avez déjà utilisé pour John
Palet, je crois. Euh
non, je pense que
comment dire
la la violence, ça peut être aussi de
de sous-payer des gens
dans tout un pays. Ça c'est violent.
Créer de la misère et de la précarité,
c'est violent.
Mais c'est bizarre, on utilise pas ce
mot là.
On va l'enrober dans d'autres vocabules.
Est-ce que si on paye tout le monde à
5000 € par mois et qu'on se met à
consommer tous avec 5000 € par mois, ça
ça va créer quoi ?
Un gros problème. Ça va créer un gros
problème. C'est tout le contraire.
C'estd que
je disais tout à l'heure, j'ai je
participe je crois plus au manif
je crois plus du tout à au manif on va
revendiquer d'avoir plus d'argent pour
consommer plus. Je peux pas participer à
ça.
On devrait pas tous être à 5000. On
devrait tous être beaucoup moins.
C'est beaucoup moins
pour forcément envie de c'est pas
forcément nécessaire de dire un chiffre
mais parce que ça a pas beaucoup de
sens. Je préfère utiliser les mots comme
Baptiste Milondo, un revenu suffisant
inconditionnel suffisant suffisant pour
vivre
et pas juste survivre.
Alors, je sais pas si c'est je vais pas
vous dire c'est 2000 € 2500 et cetera.
Je dis juste qu'aujourd'hui on a des
écart de salair entre le plus bas et le
plus fort dans une entreprise qui n'ont
qui sont sans commune mesure avec le
même avec dans la même entreprise les
écarts de salair il y a quelques années.
Il y a une réflexion à voir aussi
là-dessus. Est-ce que c'est décent
d'avoir un patron d'Air France qui vient
d'être d'être nommé avec le salaire
qu'il a déjà que le salaire de je sais
plus combien c'était
mais ça m'a choqué beaucoup.
Donc revenons à la manifestation.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
C'est ce que je disais. La manife elle
elle peut exister si derrière il y a il
y a il y a un blocage. Il y a un acte
fort qui fait prendre conscience ou qui
incite un gouvernement à changer sa
position.
un blocage comment
non mais je veux dire aujourd'hui on a
un blocage tout le monde reste chez soi,
on va plus bosser, on attend que ça se
passe. Un blocage, on s'assoit tous par
terre, on fait quoi ?
Et pourquoi pas ? Il y a pas une façon
de de de faire grève. Le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on fait une manife
mais derrière je vois pas par exemple
c'est c'est intéressant de regarder un
petit peu dans le passé euh comment des
des ce qu'on appelle les acquis sociaux
comment la journée de 8h a été obtenue
comment c'est c'est pas en manifestant
un dimanche que les que les Américains
ont fait changer leur leur façon de
travailler
les choses changent est-ce que les
manifestations doivent changer
Ah oui je sais pas si elles doivent
changer ou si elles doivent s'arrêter et
on passe à autre chose si elles doivent
être complétées par autre chose. C'est
qu'au début du 20e, on manifestait et on
bloqua.
Voilà, il y avait une énorme solidarité
aussi dans les entre les différents
secteurs. Aujourd'hui, enfin
a quelques mois, je vois la manive des
des fonctionnaires, la manifraités,
la manif secteur, la manif jour à des
jours différents. Enfin,
ouais. Bah non, c'est pas comme ça que
on va réussir à à montrer un front
commun où qu'on n'est pas d'accord avec
un gouvernement en étant séparé, en
manifestant un jour sur qu Non, pour moi
c'est pas c'est c'est pas ça. C'est ni
une image de solidarité
ni une image d'efficacité.
C'est l'efficacité qu'on recherche. Non.
Voilà.
Vous avez déjà organisé des
manifestations ?
Euh demander, inciter à manifester
quelque part. Ouais, c'est quand j'y
croyais encore.
Est-ce que c'est votre mandat de député
qui vous a rendu complètement blasé de
ce qui se passe ?
Alors, j'espère ne pas avoir l'air
blasé. Euh, je suis plus lucide
et donc je considère qu'il faut être
lucide
pour agir correctement dans à l'avenir.
Qu'est-ce qui rend lucide ?
D'observer. Moi, j'ai beaucoup observé
ce qui se passait autour de moi et de
d'essayer de rester un peu
voilà
dans l'émiss enfin dans dans
l'assemblée, c'est un microcosme.
C'est pas loft mais je l'ai souvent
comparé au loft.
C'est un microcosme.
Le loft pour ceux qui ont qui sont pas
de la génération
qui sont pas qui sont beaucoup plus
jeunes.
Je rappelle que vous avez 49 ans, vous
êtes né 14 novembre.
Ouais.
Ouais. Je suis Scorpion. Euh ça c'était
la le fait.
Vous croyez euh dans toutes ces
conneries ? Scorpion, Balance ? Euh
non, c'est pour c'est pour situer.
Voilà. Euh
en fait euh j'ai j'ai eu la sensation
pendant 5 ans d'être, je dis pas une
ethnologue ou une sociologue qui regarde
ce qui se passe dans le bocal.
un peu un peu quand même. Regardez
comment les comment les relations
humaines s'articulent, comment le
pouvoir change les gens, comment la le
fait de d'imaginer qu'on a du pouvoir
fait qu'on va plus parler aux autres de
la même façon et cetera. Moi, je jeai
j'ai vu les gens changer en 6 mois.
Comment on perd complètement pied ?
C'est qui les gens ?
Bah des collègues députés.
Vous avez des noms ?
J'ai pas envie de donner de noms en
fait. Ça ça changera pas grand-chose.
Faut juste être en être conscient,
se dire
c'est pas enfoncer des portes ouvertes
tout ça.
Non
non parce que j'ai voir ses collègues
changer,
c'est
ça fait bizarre
et voir le processus de de de de
changement à cause du pouvoir comme ça
avant. Non
non, je crois pas. Je crois pas.
C'est une addiction. Le pouvoir est une
addiction. Parler d'alcoolisme tout à
l'heure, je crois que çaen est çaen est
une. Euh chercher à avoir toujours plus
de pouvoir, plus de mandats.
Plus de mandats dans le temps,
plus de pognons,
plus de pognon aussi. Mais je pense
honnêtement que c'est davantage une
histoire de pouvoir qu'une histoire
d'argent. Je crois, j'ai pas dit que ça
comptait pas, mais je pense que c'est
plus une question de pouvoir quand on
voit par exemple les gens vous parlent
différemment quand vous êtes quand vous
êtes député ou vous allez passer, on va
vous dire "Mais ne faites pas la queue
madame la députée ou qu'est-ce que je
peux vous servir madame la députée
Et ce genre de de comportement fait que
oh bah dis donc, moi j'ai
euh finalement j'ai du pouvoir. Les gens
sont vachement sympas avec moi, ils me
respectent. Ouais. Ouais. Et donc du
coup, on en veut toujours plus. On
s'habitue à ce genre de traitement.
C'est pour ça qu'il y a des gens qui
sont vitrifiés et c'est peut-être pour
ça que Macron a changé un peu tout le
monde. Non non,
je pense que
c'est intéressant de savoir pourquoi il
a changé tout le monde. Je pense que
c'est c'est pour ça que
après je considère que le non cumule des
mandats dans le temps est la priorité.
C'est pas ce qu'il a fait. Il a dû
limiter à trois mandats euh et encore on
compte pas. On remet les pendules à zéro
maintenant. C'estàd que ceux qui en ont
déjà fait trois avant vont pouvoir en
faire trois autres. Waouh ! Génial !
Super la réforme. Euh en fait, oui, il y
a eu un renouvellement parce que je
pense les gens il ont cru se sont dit
ralbol des vieux schnou de la politique,
ils sont toujours là et cetera. On va
remplacer par des jeunes. Si c'est pour
que les jeunes fassent la même chose que
les vieux faisaient avant, euh quel est
l'intérêt ? Quel est l'intérêt ?
On fait comment pour réveiller les gens
? Et quel pouvoir en tant que député ?
Alors, question d'internet.
J'ai pas mal pensé à la question
qu'est-ce que je peux faire à mon petit
niveau ? Parce que je évidemment vu de
l'extérieur, on se dit pourquoi elle dit
petit niveau ? Était quand même député.
Bon euh ouais
à 5000 balles par mois.
5004 ça c'est marrant, c'est
inflationniste.
Je suis pas sûr qu' qu'il soit
nécessaire de faire une fixette sur le
sur le salaire des députés. C'est pas
moi qui l'ai fixé. Qu quand François
Ruffin il reste à 1500 € et qui reverse
son pognon à des assauts, qui vient avec
des chaussures trouées en interview chez
nous et qui se défonce H24 pour sa
politique. Pourquoi ils font pas tout ça
les autres ?
Est-ce que vous voulez que tout le monde
fasse ça ? Alors c'est j'ai pas trop
envie de détailler le sujet. J'ai j'ai
dit ma position. J'ai dit que je
trouvais ça un peu démago.
C'est démago. Pourquoi ? parce que euh
bon on n' pas tous les mêmes les mêmes
revenus hein euh à côté.
Euh il y en a qui peuvent baisser
beaucoup leur salaire. Moi je sais que
j'ai
référence à ses droits sur
Ouais. Non non mais je veux dire c'est
c'est euh c'est évident. Et puis à
l'assemblée, il y en a plein d'autres.
Ils ont une autre ils ont le droit
d'avoir une autre activité qui rapporte
de l'argent.
Euh il y a il y a des dizaines d'années
à l'Assemblée
euh le salaire a été augmenté pour que
on puisse avoir des députés qui ne
soient pas des que des notables. Parce
qu'avant quand les sal quand les députés
avaient des tout petits salaires, alors
je parle d'il y a 80 100 ans,
du coup les seuls qui pouvaient exercer
un mandat de députés, c'était des
notaires, des avocats, des médecins, des
rentiers,
des bourgeois. Et on avait une une élite
finalement politique bourgeoise qui
avait les moyens de s'offrir le luxe
d'être presque pas payé pour être
député. Il y a eu des il y a eu une
réforme complète de façon à ce que les
députés soient correctement payés pour
que tout le monde
puisse être député de l'ouvrier au de
l'ouvrier au notaire.
Ruffin c'est un bourgeois.
Non, c'est j'ai jamais dit ça. Puis j'ai
pas envie de critiquer François parce
que je j'apprécie ce qu'il fait. Il fait
ce qu'il peut à l'assemblée. Il fait ce
qu'il peut
clairement.
Bah oui, dans la limite de de ce qu'on
laisse comme liberté à des députés. Tout
à l'heure, on disait qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ? Moi, je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire euh plus en circonscription
chez soi que forcément dans l'hémicycle
où il y a beaucoup de théâtre, il y a
beaucoup de shows et cetera. Euh je
pense que quand on est sur le terrain,
on peut organiser, faire des tests, des
expériences de démocratie, de démocratie
locale, de vraie démocratie. Bon,
j'avais essayé de le faire avec les
juris citoyens, dire, je tirais au sort,
je crois beaucoup au tirage au sort.
Donc je tirais au sort neuf personnes
qui travaillaient toute seule pour
répartir la réserve parlementaire qui
était de 130000 € par an. Les dossiers,
les les projets arrivaient et c'était
eux qui choisissaient. C'était pas moi.
Je leur faisais confiance jusqu'au bout.
C'est eux qui décidaient de la somme, de
qui, pourquoi, de l'argumentaire et
cetera. C'est ce genre d'expérience là
qui vaut le coup d'être tenté et qui est
justement possible. quand on est député,
on peut l'organiser. Il y en a d'autres.
Il y a d'autres exemples. J'aurais bien
aimé, par exemple, si j'avais été vrai
élu, euh j'avais dit que j'aimerais que
sur un projet de loi en particulier, je
puisse avoir une une assemblée citoyenne
tirée au sort d'une trentaine, 40
personnes qui décortiquent ce projet de
loi, qui fassent des propositions et
cetera eux-mêmes comme si c'était eux
les élus. Euh ouais, financièrement,
mais justement je on a un peu d'argent
pour faire fonctionner pour faire notre
travail de député, autant le mettre là
dedans. Voilà, c'est un c'est mais c'est
un choix, c'est toujours c'est toujours
des des choix d'orienter plus le budget
vers tel ou tel dans tel ou tel domaine.
Moi, je j'aurais aimé qu'on puisse plus
l'orienter vers des expériences de
participation démocratique. Vrai,
ça sert pas à faire de la subordation de
vote.
B Non, justement, parce qu'on tire au
sort des gens, ils se débrouillent. Euh
c'est comme les autres.
Ouais.
Euh alors le clientélisme il est
partout. Euh
ça existe toujours.
Bien sûr.
Chez qui ?
Euh chez qui ? J'en sais rien parce que
je les ai pas étudié en particulier mais
euh quand vous envoyez certains qui vont
défendre plus un secteur qu'un autre en
fonction de s'il y a une grosse
entreprise dans leur circonscription, ça
va être le sujet de dont ils vont
parler. Si vous plus défendre les
chasseurs par exemple,
ils essayent de sauver l'emploi. Non,
ça ça oui, mais alors on atteint le
niveau de chantage à l'emploi.
Qu'il y a des grosses boîtes qui des
patrons qui vont venir vous voir en tant
que députés et qui vont dire "Vous savez
sur ce texte, ça serait mieux de voter
comme si comme ça parce que sur votre
nous avons quand même 3000 emplois dans
votre région." En gros, ça veut dire si
vous votez pas comme nous on vous dit de
voter, vous menacez enfin vous risquez
de perdre 3000 emplois. C'est quand même
dommage pour votre réputation de député.
Oui, je l'ai eu.
De qui ?
Euh, Orange.
Non, il vous non
ils vous ont fait ça
si c'était pas aussi enfin là j'étais
orange ou c'était pas un lobbyiste ou
quelque chose ? Là, je fais du
commentaire de texte. Enfin, j'explique
en gros, mais c'était c'est des visites
que qu'on reçoit en tant qu'élu de
patron qui vous disent
euh euh voilà notre position,
nous avons le plaisir de vous annoncer
que nous nous représentons
3000 emplois ou 6000 ou voire plus. Euh
c'est normal,
mais bien sûr, je les en je je les
empêche pas de faire leur boulot, quoi
que ça s'appelle. Enfin, c'est pas des
menaces mais c'est très appuyé quand
même hein comme argument. Vous
jamais critiqué. Vous le percevez comme
ça.
Euh ouais ouais, c'est ça.
Je l'ai je l'ai interprété comme ça. Euh
j'empêche pas les lobbyistes de faire
leur travail. Enfin si j'aimerais qu'il
soit déclaré sur un registre obligatoire
comme à Bruxelles. Caron parle souvent
des lobbyistes de Bruxelles.
C'est pas le cas en France.
En France non. À l'Assemblée c'est il y
a un registre où ils doivent se faire
inscrire. C'est pas obligatoire.
Voilà.
Ah, c'est une piste de réflexion. Si
quelqu'un veut veut s'y attaquer, ça
serait pas mal.
J'ai pas j'ai j'ai rien contre le fait
d'avoir un groupe de personnes qui
cherchent à défendre ses intérêts.
C'est normal, c'est logique. Dans le
monde dans lequel on vit, c'est normal.
Par contre, le rôle de l'élu, il est de
se faire une opinion personnelle
après avoir écouté
euh les les les les différents points de
vue. Après, il décide, c'est pas de
gober et de recracher directement les
amendements des lobbyistes.
Suis-je clair ?
Voilà,
une question d'internet. Le GC du 8
octobre, vous en attendez quoi ?
Ah, bonne question.
Je me doute que à nouveau des
alertes sur le peu de temps qui nous
reste pour modifier la trajectoire par
rapport à la biodiversité, au
réchauffement climatique et cetera vont
être ça va être là comme les précédentes
rencontres comme les précédents
ou euh
la COP 21 ou la COP 22 ou la COP 18 ou
la COP 2000 2036
Laurent Fabus a pas sauvé le monde.
Non, il aura pas de il pourra pas avoir
de prix Nobel. Non, il aurait peut-être
dû s'occuper de la farge en siré plutôt.
Mais bon.
Euh,
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la Syrie
d'ailleurs ?
Alors, la Syrie, capitale Damas, 18
millions d'habitants, langue officielle
l'arabe. Non, euh,
j'ai eu une position assez ferme et
assez isolée à l'Assemblée il y a
quelques années puisque j'avais voté
contre les frappes les frappes
aériennes.
On était deux.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que justement, j'avais pu discuter
avec des avec des chercheurs qui
spécialisés sur la Syrie.
Vous étiez quatre. Non, on était deux.
Les autres c'était des erreurs de vote.
Euh, ils sont déclarés après que c'était
des erreurs en fait.
Et euh moi je considérais que les les
dégâts collatéraux
allaient être beaucoup trop importants
pour les les civils. Je considérais que
en tant que député, on avait zéro
information
sur pourquoi on bombarde,
ce que ça va provoquer, ce que qu'est-ce
qu'on fait après les bombardements.
Enfin, on on ne connaît rien et on nous
demande de d'appuyer sur un bouton pour
dire oui ou non. Et ça, c'est pas
possible.
Il y a pas des gens qui vous expliquent
qui Non, on a une parole gouvernementale
qui nous arrive et on nous dit il faut
absolument voter voter oui pour pour
bombarder. C'est ça la parole qu'on
reçoit. Après à nous d'aller poser des
questions et de se dire "Bon, je vais
peut-être pas c'est peut-être faux,
est-ce qu'on m'a tout raconté et cetera
?"
Le résultat c'est quoi ? C'est que tout
le monde a tout le monde a voté. Oui.
Alors après c'est interprété, c'était
Ah, elle a voté contre. Donc c'est
qu'elle elle défend Bachar Elassad. Non,
je défends pas Bachar Elassad. Il y a un
aspect de la Syrie qui m'intéresse
vraiment, c'est la partie nord et
nord-est, c'est-à-dire l'Euro Roja Java.
Et ce qui se passe au Roja Java mérite
toute notre attention.
Vous connaissez la Syrie, vous avez été
sur place ?
Jamais et mais j'aimerais bien aller
là-bas.
Vous faites comment ? Vous faites
comment pour vous informer ? Question
d'internet ?
Pour nous informer, je reçois pas enfin
je fais la distinction, je suis plus élu
donc je reçois pas le même le même stock
d'info. Mais
les élus quand on il reçoivent quoi
comme stock d'info ?
On a des messages perso, on a des
messages de de de gens qui se sentent
concernés sur des sujets en particulier.
Ça peut être des amateurs éclairés, des
gens qui ont bossé sur un sujet
énormément, qui sont pas scientifies,
qui sont rien du tout, mais qui en
connaissent suffisamment et qui vous
disent "Attention euh là euh il va y
avoir un sujet qui va être évoqué au
Parlement bientôt. Euh est-ce que vous
êtes au courant que de votre vote
découle telle ou telle ou telle
conséquence ? J'ai des gens qui sont
venus me voir pour m'expliquer le
fonctionnement des crématoriums.
Bon, alors ça peut paraître complètement
bizarre mais voilà, moi je connaissais
rien en fonctionnement des crématoriums.
J'ai des gens qui sont venus me voir
avant la le vote sur le projet de loi
sur la la biodiversité pour m'expliquer
que euh l'Office national de la chasse
et de la faune sauvage euh fonctionnait
pas correctement ou que l'ONF
fonctionnait pas correctement. Euh il y
a des gens qui demandent des rendez-vous
et bah moi j'avais envie d'écouter tous
ces gens-là. J'avais vraiment envie.
Donc bah je je les recevais.
Alors députés en général on on est
obligé de toucher à tout.
On peut on a du mal à être spécialiste
d'un domaine. On nous demande de voter
sur tous les domaines. Donc on essaie au
moins par respect pour les lois qu'on
vote d'en apprendre le plus possible.
Après, il y a des limites peut-être de
ce que notre cerveau peut accumuler
comme connaissance, mais euh j'y
connaissais pas grand-chose dans
certains domaines et j'étais obligé de
me former, quoi. Et euh je le regrette
pas.
Vous êtes formé euh en dehors des
crématorium ?
Ouais. Ouais.
par exemple sur le numérique,
j'en connaissais un petit bout mais je
suis très
enfin je me sens mieux aujourd'hui
d'avoir pu côtoyer des assauts, d'avoir
d'avoir pu défendre le logiciel libre,
d'avoir pu travailler avec la quadrature
et d'avoir su aller chercher aussi des
gens qui s'y connaissent et qui m'ont
apporté un éclairage
extrêmement important pour moi. Le
logiciel libre pour moi est important,
c'est crucial. D'où mes questions sur à
tous les ministères de façon récurrente
chaque année pour savoir quelle part de
logiciel libre ou de logiciel
propriétaire ils avaient ils dans dans
lesquels ils investissaient chaque
année.
Le fait qu'il y a un système
d'exploitation français en open source
qui est en train de sortir là, ça vous
intéresse ?
Ouais.
Comment il s'appelle ?
C'est pas Caliopen. Non, c'est pas c'est
quoi ? Je sais plus. Non non, c'est
autre chose. On est sur autre chose.
Mais euh
après je je me méfie aussi des
J'avais bien rigolé quand qui avait
parlé de défendre l'internet
l'internet français au CAS avait dit
qu'il avait rencontré les grands les
grands les grands chefs de l'internet
quand il était dans la cité silicone
Vallé. Je crois question d'internet. Les
médias influencent-il les députés ? Si
oui, lesquels ? Les médias,
ça va encore dire quelque chose les
médias maintenant ?
Bah justement, je sais pas trop la
question, on est sur des médias
mainstream. Influence-il les députés ?
Euh les députés veulent passer dans les
médias,
quasiment tous. Euh donc
vont pas faire le tri, ils vont pas
faire le tri, ils vont accepter.
Est-ce que ça influence ?
Ouais, je pense que c'est plus ce qui
influence les députés, ça va plutôt être
quels sont les sujets qui qui plaisent
le plus à la population et à leurs
électeur
d'innet, pardon.
Non, vas-y.
Question d'internet. Si elle tombe de
l'arbre si tard, qu'est-ce qu'il a
aveuglé pendant si longtemps ?
Qu'est-ce qui m'a aveuglé pendant si
longtemps ?
le fait d'être baigné dans dans un
système capitaliste qui est celui que
j'ai toujours connu,
de croire qu'on pouvait juste le
modifier à la marge, le rendre plus
humain. Je crois que j'ai dû dire ça un
jour même, le rendre plus humain et de
réaliser que mais c'est complètement
complètement avérant quoi. C'est
complètement faux.
Euh alors, je préfère être tombé de
l'arbre maintenant que plus tard. Vaut
mieux tard que jamais, c'est cas de le
dire. Et je pense qu'on est tous euh on
est tous sur un parcours différent à
différentes alures, différents rythmes.
Euh c certains ont pris euh conscience
du du problème des problèmes il y a il y
a 20 ans, d'autres il y a 3 ans. Moi,
c'était il y a il y a un an.
Euh j'avais pris conscience d'autres
choses. Je me battais sur pas mal
d'autres sujets en particulier
effectivement celui des des libertés
individuelles.
Et
même si on se rend compte de pas mal de
choses, c'est le degré de gravité ou
c'est l'urgence qu'on perçoit pas parce
queon pas envie de s'en rendre compte.
L'humain fait que on n pas envie de de
de penser
à aux catastrophes, à qu'est-ce qui va
se passer demain si s'il y a plus de
pétrole, si les centrales nucléaires
nous pètent à la gueule. Il y aura
toujours du pétrole, hein. Après, c'est
à quel prix ?
À quel prix exactement ? À quel prix ?
Je suis d'accord. Combien il faudra de
baril pour en extraire, pour en
récupérer ? Combien ? Ça c'est vrai. Euh
est-ce qu'on réfléchit aujourd'hui à
autre chose, un autre modèle, une autre
façon de produire ? Est-ce que les
énergies renouvelables sont l'avenir ?
Je sais pas. Est-ce que me pose aussi
beaucoup de questions ? Je pense que je
me remets en question et je me pose sans
arrêt des de nouvelles questions.
Quand vous étiez député,
Ouais.
il vous est arrivé de vous retrouver
avec tout le monde contre vous ?
Ouais. sur l'état d'urgence, sur des
sujets comme ça. Qu'est-ce qui vous a
donné la force intérieurement
d'encaisser euh les attaques
personnelles, les coûts euh les petits
arrangements euh pour vous faire terre ?
Si ça si ça un jour existait ? H
qu'est-ce qui vous anime ? C'est c'est
quoi la force intérieure d'Isabelle
Attard ?
Euh j'ai j'ai rien à à prouver, j'ai
rien à vendre. Euh j'ai pas à faire
plaisir à à qui que ce soit pour être
réélu ou pas. Ma vie c'est pas la
politique. Ma vie ne s'arrête pas à
l'hémicycle.
les les convictions que j'avais par
rapport aux libertés, à la censure, à
l'autocensure.
Euh, j'avais placé tellement ça haut
dans la valeur de ce qui des choses à
défendre qu'effectivement c'est pas euh
je suis restée accrochée à ces
convictions là. Ce qui m'a aidé à tenir
euh je l'ai je l'ai dit des fois, c'est
aussi les réseaux sociaux, c'est aussi
Twitter. Alors, peut-être que si je suis
si accroché à Twitter, c'est parce que
pendant pendant pas mal de temps, c'est
grâce à la à la rapidité euh de la
réactivité de Twitter que j'avais euh
par exemple
euh ça me donnait la force dans
l'hémicycle parce que j'avais
commentaires sur "Ouais, c'est bien, euh
allez-y, lâchez pas, lâchez rien euh
parce que sinon on est seul, hein."
Plus de 15000 followers.
Ouais,
peut-être parce que ça intéresse de les
gens de savoir ce qu'il faut faire
après, ce que j'ai envie de faire après
ou mes réactions à l'actualité
intéressent toujours. Euh mais
alors, j'aimerais bien aussi qu'on parle
de Mastodon parce que pas que de Twitter
mais voilà
plaisir
et voilà donc si d'autres personnes
pouvaient nous rejoindre sur maçon, ce
serait génial. Voilà, j'ai fait mon
petit tabel, j'ai ma pub. Voilà. Et puis
mon objectif, il est aussi de migrer
petit à petit. Voilà. De quitter de
quitter Facebook et
là vous êtes en train de migrer en
Bretagne.
Ouais.
Ils sont sympas les Bretons, hein ?
Très
accueillons.
Attention, j'ai pas dit que les autres
l'étaient pas non plus, mais coude.
Conscient.
Pourquoi elle est là-bas ? Bah un ça
fait partie de ça fait partie des des
principales raisons, c'est que
à cause des centrales nucléaires
euh fait que c'est le seul la seule qui
est pas en fonctionnement. Alors elle
est pas encore démantelé hein. Brenil
c'est pas démantelé et apparemment ce
sera pas avant 2032. C'est ça que ça
c'est gênant dans nos plans. Mais disons
que c'est au moins la région la la moins
nucléarisée. On va dire peut-être
qu'après il y a la Creuse.
Donc la Bretagne a causé centrale. Oui.
C'est très sympa en Creuse aussi. Mais
oui, tout à fait. Euh par contre, il y a
moins de Je pense qu'il y a moins de
réseau militant. Je connais un peu la
Creuse quand même. Et même si c'est très
sympa, très vert et on pourra faire
pousser plein de choses, euh
la force du réseau militant Breton a été
influent sur notre choix. Ensuite, il y
a le on a rayé de la carte tout le sud
de la France du réchauffement
climatique.
Ouais.
Donc là, vous allez faire quoi ? Vous
allez faire du survivalisme, de
l'autogestion. Vous appelez ça comment ?
Ah, on appelle ça un tiu déjà. Euh, on
va essayer, on va habiter et avoir une
activité pro. Euh
le but, si j'essaie de résumer en
quelques mots, hein, c'est de
l'éducation populaire politique et j'ai
pas je pas m'en cacher. Euh on a besoin
de pouvoir euh regrouper sur place et
tout tout ce qui est réflexion sur
l'autonomie alimentaire, l'autonomie
énergétique euh mais pas que.
faut que ça soit un lieu qui vive où on
fasse des conférences, des des
projections, on prend un documentaire,
on on en débat après et ça sera en
pleine cambrouse. Oui, justement, c'est
un challenge le faire en zone rurale.
J'y arrive plus, je sature par rapport à
la ville, par rapport aux villes en
général, j'arrive plus du tout
à essayer de faire un lieu où on peut
réfléchir tranquillement ou peut-être
qu'on déconstruit le modèle dans lequel
on a toujours vécu et on se reforge
grâce à l'anarchie, hein, aussi.
une autre façon de voir les choses.
Quand je dis on parle d'autogestion,
oui, bon, c'est le synonyme d'anarchie
he pour le fonctionnement d'une
entreprise ou fonctionnement d'un même
d'un groupe. Euh
éducation populaire, on pense souvent
aussi au scout.
Bon bah dans chez les SCOT, il y a aussi
des réflexions sur comment on fait pour
faire de la démocratie à l'intérieur
d'un groupe, par exemple.
Et j'adore voir ça. J'adore voir qu'il y
a cette réflexion là partout.
Comment on prend les décisions.
Est-ce que c'est ensemble où il y a un
chef ou un leader un leader suprême ?
Bon, je pense qu'on est capable tous de
participer à l'émancipation.
L'émancipation, c'est fondamentalin.
Ça veut dire être capable de de prendre
ses distances par rapport au modèle
capitaliste aussi.
Et si il y a une chose à lire, ce serait
de regarder sur du côté de l'écologie
sociale demi Bchin.
Pourquoi c'est pourquoi c'est si
important à mes yeux ce que ce que cet
homme, cet essayiste, c'est pas
philosophe mais a pu écrire, c'est que
justement il se il se bat pour que pour
l'émancipation de chaque personne
et pour le collectif et pour l'écologie
et pour le féminisme, pour tous ces ces
dimensions là qui forgent finalement la
personnalité et qui fait qu'on va avoir
une vie plus agréable et un esprit mieux
formé. Euh c'est le contraire de ce que
par exemple quelqu'un comme Macron est
en train de faire.
Lui, son souhait d'avoir une armée de
moutons, de gens obligés de prendre
n'importe quel boulot qui ne qui
réfléchissent le moins possible et qui
achètent ce qu'on leur demande
d'acheter.
Ça c'est la société dans laquelle on vit
aujourd'hui. Est-ce que est-ce qu'on
peut essayer de de de faire une
expérience de pensée euh vous et moi,
par rapport à Macron et de se dire euh
certes, il a été poussé par euh certains
évadés fiscaux euh pour euh arriver au
pouvoir où il a été poussé par certains
réseaux euh pour essayer de défendre la
France dans une période de guerre
économique sanglante h
pour peut-être limiter la chute ou
peut-être ralentir la perte de puissance
de la France. Non. Est-ce que vous avez
essayé de concevoir le le modèle
macronien comme ça ?
Non, je l'ai jamais perçu comme ça. Donc
c'est difficile de l'imaginer comme ça.
Je pense qu'il est là pour faire
perdurer le système le plus longtemps
possible et euh le faire aller euh le
plus vite possible, encore plus voilà
vers finalement le le capitalisme
sauvage. Ça oui, j'y crois.
Mais pour faire quoi ? pour redorer le
blason de la France à l'étranger
économiquement parlant pour vendre plus
d'erbus, plus de rafale, enfin plus de
plus de quoi ? Plus de centrale
nucléaire à l'étranger.
[Musique]
Voilà c'est vous savez sur le terrain
quand on quand vous entendez les gens
vous dire pourquoi ils ont voté pour
Macron, il y a pas de notion de
géopolitique ou d'économie.
Ils ont fait un vote utile.
Non, c'est pire que ça. Il y en a pas
mal. C'est parce qu'il était beau gosse
quoi.
C'est une blague ?
Non, c'est pas une blague.
Non.
Bon, les gars, il va falloir qu'on se
présente au présidentiel.
Euh, question d'internet.
Ouais.
C'est quoi un bon écolo ?
À savoir qui c'est qui pose ce genre de
question. Euh, alors je vais essayer
d'être simple. Pour moi, un bon écolo,
c'est un écolo radical,
pas au sens extrémiste, au sens radical,
aller aux sources du problème.
Euh
quelqu'un qui essaie d'être cohérent,
on n'est pas parfait. On est tous sur un
chemin de vie qui essaie d'un peu d'être
cohérent entre ses idées et sa façon de
vivre.
Euh voilà. Est-ce que ça répond à la
question ? Je sais pas.
C'est votre réponse, hein.
Ouais.
Euh un écolo, un bon écolo, est-ce qu'il
fait des enfants ?
Pourquoi ça vous fait marrer ?
Ça me fait marrer parce que j'en ai
quatre. Donc on pourrait dire wou la
vache en terme de surpopulation, elle a
fait fort.
Non mais après vous êtes tombé tard de
l'arbre donc bon. Ouais, c'est ça.
Euh,
disons que c'est un écolo qui euh c'est
pas forcément qu'il fait beaucoup
d'enfants ou pas beaucoup d'enfants,
c'est qu'il apprend à ses enfants à
vivre en laissant le moins d'impact
écolo quoi. Ouais, c'est ça.
Le moins d'impact sur le le
sur les ressources, sur le vivant, sur
les autres espèces. Euh il y a pas il y
a il y a il y a une notion que j'ai
oublié de d'expliquer et qui est
fondamentale, c'est la notion de
domination.
Euh si je défends aussi farouchement les
coanarchies, c'est parce que il y a la
notion de ne pas dominer les autres
espèces,
euh de pas dominer cette la femme quand
on est un homme, d'où la part importante
du féminisme,
de dominer quand on est blanc sur
quelqu'un qui serait de couleur et
cetera et cetera
et dominer quelqu'un qui est moins
intelligent.
Ça fait partie aussi de la question
quand on souhaite l'émancipation de
chacun.
Euh c'est pour avoir des individus qui
sont heureux,
qui acquent des connaissances celles
qu'ils ont choisie, euh capable
d'analyser ce qui se passe dans
l'actualité, d'analyser le monde dans
lequel ils vivent en pleine conscience
en étant pas juste des des moutons ou
euh ou des gens qui vont tout absorber.
Et c'est pas une critique du mouton. Je
fais une critique de ceux qui fabriquent
ce modèle de pensée.
C'est qui ceux ?
Par exemple,
bah vous avez tous les fans d'Edouard
Bernz parce que vous avez vu le le super
doc propaganda. Je le conseille à tout
le monde.
C'est un livre à la base.
Ouais, mais je le documentaire en 52
minutes pour ceux qui ont pas le temps.
Euh, on peut aussi lire les
en moins de 52 minutes.
Ouais. Non, mais on peut Non, non, non.
Je conseille à personnes de lire en
diagonale, mais on peut aussi regarder
ce qui écrit auzin euh dans son histoire
populaire des États-Unis parce qu'il en
parle aussi. Mais euh de comprendre les
mécanismes où de manipulation des
foules, de manipulation des masses euh
quand on parle d'émancipation, c'est
bien pour lutter contre le la
manipulation des foules. On est on est
en plein dans ce dans un schéma à 180°.
Vous avez lu Gustave Lebon
euh
Ouais. Non non, je l'ai pas lu. Je sais
que je c'est c'est quelque chose qui
m'intéresse encore énormément de savoir
comment lui-même a pu influencer Bernz
et et Consortor.
Cette
on est encore on est bien sûr en plein
dedans.
On peut se poser la question pour chaque
chaque fait d'actualité pour pour les
émeutes Nutella, pour même l'élection de
Macron, mais pas que.
Euh
chaque phénomène qui semble complèement
irrationnel.
C'était passionnant d'ailleurs de voir
comment il a réussi. Bern a réussi à
faire fumer les femmes pour vendre plus
de clops. C'est c'est ce qui est le plus
marrant, c'est pourquoi on les a fait
voter.
Pourquoi on a fait voter les femmes ?
Ah ben c'était pour justement le vote
conservateur parce qu'on considérait que
comme elles étaient à la maison des
femmes au foyer, elles allaient pouvoir,
ça c'est une des explications qu'elles
allaient pouvoir voter plus à droite.
Si elles votaient, ell peut-être leur
compte en banque et puis après on
pouvait les taxer. Non.
Ouais. Mais quelle était la première des
motivations ? Je sais pas. attendez que
c'est des élus qui mettent en place des
réformes. Euh c'est peut-être aussi pour
sauver leur siège qui vont qui
réfléchissent à qui va voter.
Si jamais on vous dit demain les les
moins de les les moins de 18 ans ont
tendance à voter plutôt pour tel
parti ont tout intérêt à faire voter le
vote le vote obligatoire à 16 ans.
Pourquoi pas ?
Vous avez une petite idée en tête ?
Non, je suis pas forcément je suis pas
favorable au vote au vote à 16 ans parce
que je me pose déjà des questions sur le
pourquoi aller voter. Donc
je risque pas de de Le vote pour moi
n'est pas
synonyme de démocratie, pas synonyme de
fonctionnement de la démocratie. Il y a
d'autres façons de la faire vivre que
d'aller voter.
Vous êtes pour la grève du vote.
J'envisage pas mal. par exemple pour les
la présidentielle de 2022, un boycott de
la présidentielle
et une contre présidentielle,
ça c'est encore une bonne éc
une contre présidentielle. Voilà, on
fait autre chose.
Encore une bonne idée ça, non ?
Un boycott de la présidentielle. Je
crois pas au leader suprême, je l'ai
déjà dit.
Euh je je j'y crois pas du tout et je
crois pas non plus au fonctionnement de
il y a pas de séparation des pouvoirs,
il y a pas de
voilà,
j'ai une vague idée, une petite idée de
qui dirige vraiment euh le pays. Donc
euh c'est qui ?
Pour moi, c'est les multinationales et
la finance,
c'est pas pas les élus.
Voilà. Donc donc pourquoi les voter ? On
pourrait tous se poser la question.
Je crois quand même encore au
pouvoir qui reste au niveau au niveau
local. Alors, certains diront peut-être
qu'il reste un pouvoir au niveau
européen. Euh, j'en suis pas convaincu
du tout. Et par contre, peut-être qu'au
niveau local, il reste quelques
compétences pour les élus de pouvoir
faire changer les choses et au plus
petit, au plus au plus bas de l'échelle.
C'est le municipalisme libertaire, c'est
euh on fédère les communes entre elles.
C'est ce qui se passe au R Java, c'est
ce qu'ils essayent de faire justement.
d'appliquer ce principe là et c'est
intéressant de voir comment ça marche et
de les suivre et de les aider.
Vous connaissez notre chaîne internet ?
Oui.
Depuis combien de temps ?
Est-ce que vous étiez encore député ?
Ah ouais, un an pas quand j'étais
député. Non, après.
Peut-être trop la tête dans le guidon.
Et non,
depuis oui.
Vous avez vu quoi ? Ah, qu'est-ce que
j'ai vu ? euh
les hackers
qui étaient toi et Bluetooth parce que
j'ai j'ai aussi eu besoin de leur de
leur éclairage pour certaines questions.
Amésici Cosmos par exemple. Euh
vous êtes invité au mariage ?
Non.
Euh
Amésis Cosmos.
Ouais. Pour pour Je fais un résumé.
Ouais. c'est euh les systèmes d'écoute
des réseaux de télécommunication qui m'
été vendu par une boîte française à la
Libye et qui a permis ensuite au
gouvernement libyen de torturer des des
opposants au régime. Voilà. Après,
on invite notre communauté à revoir
cette interview pour avoir plus de de
précision pour
complètement parce que c'est pas le
sujet d'aujourd'hui, mais
voir si Isabelle a bien résumé ou pas.
Euh d'ailleurs, c'est c'est intéressant
parce que j'ai eu j'ai reçu à
l'assemblée le responsable de Cosmos
ensuite qui est venu me dire à quel
point c'était pas gentil ce que j'avais
fait de poser une question au
gouvernement sur sa boîte et que
j'allais certainement
rendre malheureux les enfants des
salariés de cosmos parce que je
focalisais sur
je je portais leurs parents responsables
de ce qui se passait en Libye. J'ai
jamais fait ça, mais c'était un moment
intéressant, très intéressant.
Euh donc oui, j'ai regardé quelques
interviews, celle de François Ruffin,
celle de
Pierre Lutourou,
celle de les récentes. Oui, beaucoup.
Mais j'en avais non
Non, pas encore.
Alors, c'est si dur que ça de passer
chez nous ?
Est-ce que j'ai dit que c'était dur ?
Non, j'ai jamais dit que c'était dur.
On est méchant
euh précis et allant jusqu'au bout. Oui,
mais ça s'appelle pas de la méchanceté.
Quelle est la dernière question qu'on
pose à nos invités ?
La bouteille à la mer
et ce qu'on veut laisser au aux plus
jeunes ou à ceux qui nous écoutent.
Ouais.
J'ai pas mal de choses, des conseils de
lecture. Un conseil tout court en
premier que je placerai certainement
tout en haut, c'est voyager le plus
possible. Prenez toutes les occasions
pour vous barrer
avec des chaussures, pas d'empreinte
carbone.
Non, en stop si vous pouvez ou comme
vous voulez. En fait, c'est ça m'est
complètement légal la façon dont vous
voyagez de façon à à voir autre chose, à
voir les gens vivre différemment que
vous, d'être curieux.
Et c'est assez particulier parce que il
y a il y a un compte que je déteste
par-dessus tout, un truc pour enfants
que je déteste, c'est la chèvre de
monsieur Segin où on apprend on apprend
au gamin que si vous sortez, si vous
êtes curieux, si vous avez envie de
liberté, vous à la fin de la nuit vous
êtes bouffé par le loup. C'est partie
des trucs. J'ai jamais pu le lire à mes
gosses. Euh donc
vous conseillez pas la chèvre de
monsieur Sean ?
Non. Donc je conseille
évidemment me re Bouchin, je conseille
de regarder aussi au niveau des BD, de
regarder l'an 1 de GB, de regarder
Auguste Lebonde avec résilience
de de regarder aussi l'essai tentative
de construction d'une ferme anarchiste
au début de au début du 20e dans les
Ardenes.
de vous bourrer aussi de documentaires,
d'aller voir justement auin parce que je
trouve que Mermé et Asan, on fait
magnifique docul de ne pas rater ni dieu
ni maître de temps crédramé
par exemple
euh et de pas hésiter à se remettre en
question sur ce qu'on a pu apprendre à
l'école, apprendre à la fac, apprendre
jusqu'à maintenant pour regarder
l'histoire avec un autre angle,
avec une autre
une analyse totalement différente
et du coup ça tout paraîtra certainement
beaucoup plus logique.
Isabelle, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]